If you're a Somali pirate,
what's the worst kind of ship you can try on board?
How about one belonging to the most powerful
navy in the world?
Because that's exactly what happened in 2006
when the pirates discovered
there's always a bigger boat.
That year, the USS Cape ST.
George and the USS
Gonzales were part of an anti piracy task force
patrolling off the coast of Somalia.
The warships were approached by a vessel
towing several skiffs.
As this was typical of pirates,
a boarding party
was sent out from the Gonzales to investigate.
The party noticed the pirates and the skiff had RPGs,
and they soon opened fired on the Cape ST. George.
Despite being heavily outgunned,
the Somali pirates nearly sank one of the US warships.
Just kidding.
They barely made a dent in Idama.
The Gonzales,
the Cape ST.
George, and the boarding party returned fire,
setting the main vessel alight
and sending it to the bottom.
Gifts were captured
and 12 of the pirates were taken prisoner.
The US chose not to charge the captives with piracy
and instead released them back to Somalia,
perhaps feeling sorry for them
for foolishly picking a fight with the wrong ship.
Like and follow.